top Chinese leaders will gather on
Sunday for the first national people's
Congress since the start of the pandemic
in recent years the meeting has been
postponed or shortened but in 2023 a
full program is in place and it'll
include an overhaul of Communist Party
leadership under President Xi Jinping
Lee Chung will officially be confirmed
as Premier taking over Lee kuchang who's
held the role for 10 years a slew of top
economic and political positions will
also be filled including Central Bank
Governor Vice and state ministers all by
officials reportedly close to see the
reshuffle follows the 20th Communist
Party Congress in October where he
secured an unprecedented third term as
China's supreme leader for the first
time in 10 years that Xi Jinping is
going to have his people leading all of
the major organs of state power in China
so the upside of that is that we could
see more efficient policy implementation
of xi's priorities but the downside is
that after the 20th party Congress has
become pretty clear that Xi Jinping
wants to continue taking China in a more
ideologically controlled more
economically statist and more
diplomatically assertive Direction there
will also be an extensive reorganization
of state and party institutions giving
XI more control of China's Financial
system
last year's growth rate of 3 was the
slowest in half a century a new Target
for gross domestic product or GDP will
be announced economists say a relatively
High figure of six percent May point to
more aggressive pro-growth policies
ahead the one thing that the government
can control is to make the state sector
stronger not necessarily bigger but
certainly more competitive and stronger
in order to provide enough support for
growth this year's Congress comes as
China faces increasing headwinds at home
the government is grappling with an
aging population and unemployment crisis
abroad Beijing is navigating an
increasingly adversarial relationship
with the United States and sanctions on
technology threaten its access to the
global market
it also follows widespread protests
against C's three-year zero covert
policy analysts are divided over how far
they damaged confidence in the
president's leadership but what is clear
is following this meeting see denping's
grip on power will be more comprehensive
and Consolidated than ever before
Katrina you Al Jazeera Beijing